this is the start of something new for
you Nene but we just wish you were
holding hands with Ricky and not EJ
we're sure he's a good guy in all but
you and Ricky are made for each other
luckily miss Jen cast you both in the
right roles and now you can be together
again even if it's only on stage we know
that Ricky hurt you when he asked to go
on a break but he never stopped loving
you we know you'll make the right choice
Nene now that Disney Plus is officially
here fans can finally feast their eyes
on High School Musical the musical the
series we spotted 10 surprising things
in the episode the auditions from Easter
eggs to casting lista everything in
between keep watching to find out the
truth about Nene's lucky sweatshirt miss
Jenn's inspiration the auditions is the
first episode of High School Musical the
musical the series and it was everything
the episode kicks off with a very
familiar clip from the original High
School Musical movie miss Jen is
watching the 2006 Disney Channel
Original Movie on her phone moments
before her first day at East High
step aside Carlos it looks like Miss
Chen is high school musicals number one
fan
Ricky puts the break in break up we
finally know the real reason why Nene
and Ricky broke up and it has everything
to do with Mimi telling Ricky she loves
him instead of saying it back Ricky
totally freaked out he pointed out that
Nene was leaving for a month and that
they should hit pause on their
relationship but the fact that Ricky
didn't say I love you back basically
meant that their relationship was over
right before Nene auditions for the role
of Gabriela EJ tells Nene that he loves
her but in total Ricky fashioned Nene
doesn't say it back so does this mean
that EJ and Nene's relationship isn't
going to last backup dancer
extraordinaire ki reindeers please
Jen the eccentric new drama teacher at
East High miss Jen is obsessed with High
School Musical and so is the actress who
plays her
did you know that Kate was a backup
dancer for the original High School
Musical movie that's right she went from
being a backup dancer to snagging one of
the lead roles in the High School
Musical series out of town
it looks like Ricky and Nene's
relationship isn't the only one that
needs saving
Ricky's parents are going through
somewhat of a rough patch and his mom
might have already moved on to someone
new throughout the first episode we find
out that Ricky's mom doesn't want to
hear from her husband Ricky also
explains that his parents never
exchanged I love yous and lastly Ricky
says that his mom spends a lot of time
out of town could Ricky's mom be dating
someone other than his dad the truth
about EJ we all want to love Ricky and
hate EJ but things aren't that simple
did any of you notice just how much EJ
cares for Nene
he's totally smitten by her he thinks
she's amazing and has complete faith in
her better yet he likes to see her
succeed and encourages her to get out of
her shell EJ even wanted me to wear a
beautiful red dress for her audition
it looks like choosing a ship is going
to be a lot harder than we thought Troy
would have arrived on time Ricky chooses
to audition for the role of Troy to win
his ex-girlfriend back but he shows up
late to the audition Carlos points out
that Troy would never have shown up late
which isn't exactly true
both Gabriela and Troy showed up to
their auditions late but that didn't
stop them from landing their desired
roles mockumentary if there's one thing
that sets the series apart from the
original movies it's the style in which
it's filmed characters get one-on-one
time with the camera which really helps
us connect with them
to think I might actually have a shot at
playing Gabrielle it's almost as if
we're watching a high school version of
The Office
we're totally digging the mockumentary
style the Leopards the original High
School Musical may have been filmed at
East High but there are still some
notable differences between both
productions Troy and Gabriella school
team was known as the Wildcats
whereas Ricky and Nene's goes by the
Leopards but that didn't stop miss Jen
from screaming go Wildcats during the
school assembly always go for the
underdogs everyone loves a good underdog
especially miss Jen which is probably
what prompted her to cast Ricky emini as
the plays leaves miss Jen saw the way
Ricky was looking at Nene during his
performance and she got the message loud
and clear
Ricky chose to sing Nene song at the
audition which would have been a total
home run if he had been able to say I
love you at the end of his performance
but for some strange reason Ricky wasn't
able to Nene's good luck sweatshirt Nene
isn't the same girl she used to be she's
much more confident and outspoken so we
thought she'd definitely want to wear a
red dress while auditioning for the role
of Gabriela but Nene chose to wear one
of her old lucky sweatshirts instead and
that got us thinking was Nene wearing
that sweatshirt the first time she met
Ricky why is he so special to her if it
weren't for the fact that it was cropped
we would have assumed it belonged to
Ricky why do you think Nene sweatshirt
is so lucky sound off in the comments
thanks for watching subscribe to the
things and don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up we'll see you next
time
you
[Music]